Good morning, John. It's Wednesday.
Argh!
[John]: Ah, chair wars!
You say it's Wednesday? It's question Wednesday, the day that I answer real questions from real nerdfighters.
Number one: "What was your biggest childhood argument?"
[Hank]: I think that you lying is the problem
where y- where something would happen, you would lie, and I would get blamed,
because you were a better liar than I was.
You're still a much better liar than I am.
[John]: I'm a novelist.
[Hank laughs]
[John]: It's, like, my job.
How come you guys never come to Ireland or even mention it?
[Hank]: Um, mentioned. [John]: Done.
Would you rather have a unicorn or a Pegasus?
[Hank]: A Pegasus, obviously. [John]: Really?
[John]: No. [Hank]: Yes.
[Hank]: It has wings.
[John]: But if you had a unicorn, you could kill it.
[Hank]: Well, you could kill the Pegasus too, if you wanted to.
You can ride a unicorn, it's like - it's just a frickin' horse.
It's like: Would you rather have a horse or a flying horse?
[John]: "Is it possible that The Giant Squid of Anger and the Sarlac from Star Wars share an evolutionary link?"
[Hank]: No. It's not, because that happened in a galaxy far, far away
and there's no way to transmit genetic material between galaxies.
[John]: It's also a long time ago.
[Hank]: Right. That's not.. that's not as big of a problem.
[John]: It's more the far, far away. [Hank]: Yeah.
[John]: "Why does the internet love bacon so much?"
[Hank]: Because bacon is delicious.
[John]: (With Southern accent) Yeah, bacon is good fer me.
Do you ever see those, uh, those anti-piracy ads, that are like: "You wouldn't download bacon."
And I'm like: "Yes I would."
[Hank]: If it was possible. [John]: Is that- is that a thing? We can download bacon?!
[Makes downloading noise]
[John Laughs] Does it come out of my printer?
"What's your favourite thing about each other?"
[Hank]: I like... this part.
[John]: Hahaha that's totally creepy. You just inspired a very unfortunate generation of fan fiction writers.
[Hank]: I think there's gonna be a Facebook fan page for this part.
What's up?
[John]: I was giving them some of that part. [Hank]: Oh [John]: So that they could make the screen cap.
[Hank]: I thought you found something up on my ceiling that I should know about. [John]: Ooh, look at that.
Wow, you have Kermit up there.
[Hank]: He's just, you know, my household god.
[John]: I mean, I have, that's where I have Padre Pio. I have a Roman Catholic saint and you have Kermit.
[Hank]: I figured Padre Pio was a soccer player. [Both laugh] Just assumed!
[John]: "Have you seen the new modernised version of Sherlock Holmes?"
[Hank]: Are we talking about the Cumberbatch one or the- the Downey Jr. one?
[John]: Because the Cumberbatch.. [Hank]: I've seen both.
[John]: The Cumberbatch one: 2 thumbs up. [Hank]: Yeees.
[John]: The Downey Jr. one: one thumb... like... [Hank]: Yeah
See, we don't disagree! [Both]: We don't disagree!
[John]: "Arm wrestling maatch!"
[Hank]: Aaarm wrestling match!
[John]: One, two, three.
[Their voices are sped up]
[John]: I give up, I give up! Argh... Aw...
"Do you guys go back and watch your old videos?"
[Hank]: That implies that we've ever watched an old video.
I never watch... [John]: Haha You never watch Brotherhood 2.0?
[Hank]: I've never seen the show.
[John]: I really enjoy watching the old videos, particularly your old videos.
When I watch my old videos, I'm pretty hard on myself.
[Hank]: It's funny because I like to watch my old videos too. [John laughs] I'm like that guy is so funny oh my god!
[John]: "Why do you do the things you do? Wouldn't it be easier to just play games all day?
What is the point of doing things in general?"
[John]: Wow. That's a...  [Hank]: What is the point of doing things in general?
There is no reason to do things. There's no, like, cosmic mandate to do stuff.
[John]: I feel bad for that person.
Because I've struggled with that a lot. In fact, I wrote a novel about it called "The Fault in Our Stars."
[Hank]: It's available in a link below. All copies will be signed.
[John]: Since there isn't, as you said, a cosmic mandate to do things, you know?
There isn't a cosmic mandate to make stuff, and the world probably won't be any different as
a result of the stuff that you make or do.
[Hank]: I think it's human nature.
I think that we have a human nature to like to do stuff and interact with people
and to make the world better for each other. [John]: Yeah. [Hank]: I think that we like doing that.
[John]: Yeah, making stuff is very fulfilling in and of itself
in a way that playing video games isn't. [Hank]: Even if it's making a garden bed
or if it's making... I mean, even you know video games are set up to do that.
They're set up to satisfy that need.
[John]: Right. Uh, but they can also become kind of insular.
[Hank]: Right, no, I mean they're set up to satisfy that need in a very shallow way.
[John]: We love making awesome stuff with awesome people.
That's what we've always loved and we feel very lucky to be part of a community where that stuff happens.
[Hank]: I'm going to turn that, right there, into a song.
[John]: Are you? [Hank]: I'm going to Songify it.
[John]: Is it going to be called "Making Awesome Stuff with Awesome People?"
Oh, you're gonna Songify me?
I'm gonna sing on key for once?!
[Hank]: I can't actually, I do not have that technology. [John laughs]
John, thank you for doing my first Question Tuesday ever with me.
[John]: It's been a privilege. [Hank]: And I will see you right now.
[John]: I will continue to see you.
[Hank]: Stop looking at me.
Stop looking at me!